hot breath how did you make the choice
to jump into comedy as a full-time
career
from an occasional hobby
[Music]
um i had an advantage in that i started
at 19 so i never
knew anything other than being broke but
if you already have an
income and rent and bills it's hard so
figure out a way to monetize
on the internet and it's going to be
hard to travel i don't even think comedy
clubs are going to be traveling features
and if they are they're not going to
give them hotels anymore so
you know that's where networking with
other comedians in the area and couch
surfing
might come into play um but for me it
was easy
i started when i was still in college so
when i came out of college i just
kept doing gigs like i never had to make
more than 350 a month to cover my
expenses until i was like 22 or 23.
um if you're doing it now you've got to
supplement income if you're on the road
figure out some day labor figure out
some tip service
you know whatever you can do to stretch
a dollar but i think the smarter way in
building an audience which is ultimately
what's going to get you leveraged
now in the industry is to figure out
ways to do that online that honor your
creative sensibilities don't become
something you aren't just for the sake
of building a following but
you know just look at it